[Applause]
the Academy presents a scientific and
engineering award to Bill spits ACK
[Music]
Jonathan egg sad
Abigail Brady John what el Tom and Jerry
Huxtable for the nuke compositing system
come again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow 15 years later this is just a
stressful
thanks so much of the Academy for this
fantastic hoard it's it's just amazing
and thanks to our wonderful families for
all the years of love and support and
patience with us and all the --ml hours
that we put into our into our work and
our enthusiastic endeavors and in
certainly thanks for the guidance and
support of the digital domain leadership
back in the day for giving us such a
creative playground in which to invent
all these crazy tools especially Doug
Robo Darren Grande and Scott Ross
[Applause]
and of course the huge thanks to the
original core compositing crew of
Digital Domain back in the 90s
20 years ago who really pushed forward
that the technology and the techniques
that really nuke came to embody
especially price Bethel and and for the
passion and persistence and not being
content with just the status quo and
finally thanks to the fabric
folks for for taking the ball and
running with it and I guess in England
that would be would actually be kicking
it so thanks thanks thanks Jonathan
thanks very much to the Academy we're
really excited about it being recognized
for this award over the last 10 years
since we at the foundry started working
on nuke above or in a dingy office above
KFC in Soho a lot has happened nuke has
become the industry standard compositing
tool for film from the drama of Titanic
the wonder of Avatar the immersion of
the Jungle Book nick has been there
touching every pixel blending the real
and the unreal together to help bring
magic to the screen it's definitely not
just us involved with this it's been a
huge team effort all the way through and
behalf of us all would would like to
thank our families our friends for
putting up with us coding late at night
or going on trips would also like to
thank the big THANK YOU to Simon
Robinson Brennan Nicoletti and Bill
Collis who were the founders of the
foundry and without them we wouldn't be
wouldn't be anywhere massive thank you
to Matt plaque as well he was the first
person that took yeah
here's a original product manager who
took on Nick from Digital Domain and
transformed it to to the product that
the foundry spent the last 10 years
working on I also like to shout out to
Jon Stark who was the head of research
did amazing work on nuclear the last 10
years and finally I really want to thank
the nuke team themselves both past and
present because they were just amazing
and I'm sure they're going to make the
next 10 years just as amazing as the
last thank you at the academy and chance
the second award because my my mom is
here today and she couldn't make it to
the first one because she she fell on
the ice on the East Coast
back then broke her wrist so I'm glad I
got to know where she could come out
here today I thank my wife
and I want to thank the yes and I want I
thank the foundry for continuing work on
this to doing such great work and
writing documentation for the thing
finally
[Applause]
for those like easiest clapper allowed
and thanks to Emma crisp in MML Mickey
ad and Keith offer pops
[Applause]